seit Wochen ist es nun still um den
günstigsten 992 GT3 Deutschlands den ich
gekauft habe das Teil welches den
größten Schaden am Auto ausmacht nämlich
die Kofferraumwanne war nicht lieferbar
und hätte den Prozess auf unbestimmte
Zeit lahm legen können es ist
unglaublich das nächste Teil dass uns
einen Strich durch die Rechnung machen
wollte und wir konnten es wieder
abwenden das Porsche Zentrum am
Nürburgring hat uns den Arsch gerettet
und das bedeutet herzlich willkommen zum
vierten Teil der Instandsetzung des
günstigsten 992 GT3 deutsch und der
gleichzeitig längsten Folge weil ihr es
euch alle gewünscht
habt ich bin im Toyota Hilux vom
Teegarten unterwegs und hinten auf der
Ladefläche liegt dieses verdammte Teil
es ist unglaublich dort seht ihr es
danke Beifahrer fürs erneute unglaublich
gute Film heißt wir können uns um die
Finalisierung aller Karosseriearbeiten
küm das Teil das uns eine Woche lang
Kopfschmerzen bereitet hat weil es nicht
lieferbar war wurde gerade von mir hier
unten seht ihr es am Nürburgring bei
Porsche direkt gekauft bedeutet wir
können jetzt doch schneller weitermachen
als gedacht bedeutet wir können vorne
hier weiter alles auseinandernhmen die
Arbeit kann weitergehen ohne Pause
richtig richtig gut auf letzten Drücker
wie immer also hieß es ran an den Speck
und die letzten Vorkehrungen treffen die
nötig sind um das neue Teil im Auto
anzupassen als erstes das Teil nur grob
in Position bringen bevor es dann ins
funing
geht so so schnell geht das vor Stunden
war dieses Teil noch am Nürburg drin im
PZ jetzt ist es eingebaut hier weil wir
vernünftige Vorarbeit geleistet haben
Vorarbeit war mit Abstand mit Abstand
viel mehr Arbeit es war aber quasi
fertig jetzt wir muss nur noch vorne ein
Teil weg maachen jetzt konnte das Teil
schon eingesetzt werden und damit das
jetzt auch wieder genau an die Originale
Stelle wieder zurückkommt haben die
messschiene und den Messarm wieder
draußen messen das ein können dann die
Löcher in das neue Teil Bohen und dann
morgen mit wirklich begrenzter Zeit das
Ding Einkleben der Kleber gibt nämlich
die sehr begrenzte Zeit vor da müssen
wir einmal noch mal alles Vorarbeiten
dass alles perfekt ist Kleber drauf
reintun festmachen und dann sind im
Prinzip alle Teile drin die getauscht
werden müssen deswegen jetzt erstmal
wieder messen jetzt gerade Höhe passt
rechts links passt aber tiefe passt noch
nicht also das neue Teil hier gerade 4
mm zu weit draußen muss also 4 mm weiter
rein und wieder einmal war ich von Andys
Arbeit unheimlich begeistert neben
krassem Fachwissen und handwerklichen
Geschick muss ich sagen das
Karosseriebau bisher der vielseitigste
Handwerksberuf war in den ich selber
reinschnuppern durfte wenn ihr also noch
nicht wisst was ihr mit eurem Leben
anfangen wollt und euch gleichzeitig für
Autos interessiert dann könnte das eine
wirklich gute Option sein und falls ihr
den Weg schon eingeschlagen habt
ausgebildet seid und wirklich was drauf
habt dann bewerbt euch bei Teegarten
über den Link in der Videobeschreibung
um an Andys Seite und so krassen
Projekten zu arbeiten und das ist keine
bezahlte Werbung oder so aber ich fei
den Job und vor allem teegart schlagen
messen
[Musik]
gucken guck mal können wir da auch noch
ein bisschen ranziehen vielleicht auch
noch mal ein bisschen weiter reinkommt
zweimal rein und raus anja hat gerade
schon gesagt Kompromisse machen 400 mit
4 mm sind wir aus dem Toleranzbereich
raus das bringt nichts jetzt sind wir
bei 2011 das ist sogar richtig gut jetzt
ziehen wir das Ding fest dann können wir
vorbauen für morgen ihr erinnert euch im
Porsche Zentrum indem der Unfall
begutachtet wurde wurde der eingedrückte
Schweller aufgeschnitten um den Schaden
wirklich begutachten zu können die
äußere Hülle des Autos ist zu großen
Teilen nämlich nicht für die Struktur
und Festigkeit des Autos verantwortlich
bedeutet so viel wie die äußere Hülle
muss weg um die wirklich wichtigen Teile
begutachten zu können und weil das schon
im Porsche Zentrum passiert und
dokumentiert ist wissen wir dass wir das
Auto ohne Probleme wunderbar reparieren
können und genau das machen wir jetzt
also Tür abbauen reinigen Schweller
anhalten und markieren und dann altes
kaputtes schwellerteil vom Fahrzeug
[Musik]
trennen so aufcam haben wir gerade schon
alles vorbereitet den Schweller
angepasst und so weiter also Ani hat's
gemacht ich habe das neue schwellerteil
vorbereitet alle Klebepunkte wieder neu
abgeschliffen die müssen alle frisch
geschliffen sein man hat dann nur 4er
Stunden Zeit das wieder zu verarbeiten
innen drin schön lackiert damit das in
Originalfarbe ist und auch noch mal
Korrosionsschutz und jetzt können wir
damit anfangen wie auch schon vorne den
Vorderwagen den die Kofferraumwanne das
neue schwellerteil einzukleben und zu
nieten eingepasst wurde es schon jetzt
rein Kleber drauf und die ganze Schose
ein zweites Mal weenn man beim
platsächlichen Kleben nur wenig Zeit hat
und im Prinzip nur einen Versuch habe
ich keine Aufnahme denn ich war am
kleben aber keine Sorge beim Vorderwagen
also dem kofferraumteil um das wir uns
gleich wieder kümmern habe ich alles
mitgefilmt dann natürlich wieder niet in
alle Löcher die Tür einhängen und einmal
kontrollieren ob alles
passt andy ist am Schweißen das Problem
ich kann es euch nicht zeigen das macht
nämlich die Kamera kaputt wenn ich da
reinfilme also nur
[Musik]
indirekt
und mit dieser grandiosen Arbeit und dem
neu angepassten Schweller endet
Arbeitstag Nummer 5 das Projekt ist
dieses Projekt ist wie immer ein
Wettrennen gegen die Zeit und seitdem
wir wissen dass alle Teile rechtzeitig
angekommen sind können wir endlich
wieder vernünftig schlafen aber nicht
nur weil es im Projekt gut läuft nein
auch durch die Produkte von Emma den
Partner des heutigen Videos denn wie
jeder von euch weiß hat nichts mehr
Einfluss auf unseren Tag als die Nacht
also eben unser Schlaf denn ich habe
gemerkt dass meine geistige und
körperliche Belastung unheimlich
schwankt je nachdem wie gut ich
geschlafen hab genauso wie ich beim GT3
nur in Originalteile investiert habe
weil mir die Qualität und das Ergebnis
wichtig sind macht ein guter Topper eine
gute Matratze und ein gutes Kissen beim
Schlaf wirklich den Unterschied ich bin
unheimlich viel unterwegs und ich kann
mit absoluter Sicherheit sagen ich
schlaf nirgendwo so gut wie zu Hause und
das aus gutem Grund ich selbst schwöre
beispielsweise auf das
premiumfauschkissen von Emma weil es zum
einen dauerhaft kühl bleibt und ich zum
anderen individuell entscheiden kann wie
hart oder weich ich liegen möchte das
Beste für euch dabei ist ihr könnt das
auch haben und zwar zu einem richtig
krassen Rabatt denn bei Emma gibt es
gerade bis zu 50% neujahrsrabatt auf
Matratzen Topper und Decken also der
perfekte Moment um im neuen Jahr euren
Schlaf in Angriff zu nehmen und in euch
und euren Schlaf zu investieren sichert
euch also jetzt bis zum 29.1 den
maximalen Rabatt im 50% Neujahr sale und
spart extra und top noch mal 5% wenn ihr
den Code Dave 911 benutzt also ersten
Link in der Videobeschreibung Auschecken
euren Schlaf optimieren und genau die
richtigen Produkte für euch finden
wieder einmal ein riesen Dankeschön an
Emmer die solche Projekte ermöglichen
und euch viel Spaß weiter mit dem Video
Tag Nummer 6 herzlich willkommen zu den
finalen Schritten des Vorderwagens wenn
geboht wird wisst ihr was das heißt das
Ding ist vernünftig eingepasst auf den
Millimeter genau andy hat das alles
gemacht noch während ich weg war
bedeutet wir können jetzt die Löcher
bohren können das Ding festziehen damit
es genauso bleibt genau das macht Andy
hier gerade schon wenn es vorgebohrt
eingepasst und festgemacht ist heißt das
wir können alles wieder rausnehmen
können noch mal alles anschleifen weil
die ganzen offenen Stellen jetzt für ein
paar Tage schon offen waren heißt wir
schleifen das noch einmal ab um sicher
zu gehen dass der Belag perfekt ist und
dann heißt es kleben und festmachen und
dann ist im Prinzip die Karosseriearbeit
die grobe Karosseriearbeit vorne gemacht
grob so wieder 6,6 mm Boher heißt ich
darf keinen einzigen Millimeter
verkacken sonst ist richtig scheiße
nachdem wir den Vorderwagen perfekt
eingepasst und vermessen haben konnten
wir endlich die Löcher bohren damit die
Wanne aber auch wirklich nicht mehr
verrutscht und wir ein letztes mal
messen können ob die Position Millimeter
genau stimmt haben wir diese
fixierstifte sor alle Karosseriebauer
ich weiß nicht mehr wie die Dinge heißen
in den gebohten Löchern festgemacht
damit das Bauteil nicht mehr verrutschen
kann bist schon völlig verrückt wenn man
das Auto jetzt so sieht ich dachte am
Anfang ja die kleine Tür als wir die
getauscht haben das sah so nach dem
einzigen Teil aus was irgendwie nicht so
ganz zum Auto gehört jetzt ist hier
hinten alles ab der Schweller ist schon
neu eingesetzt in der anderen Farbe die
Tür die Scheibe ist nicht drin hier
vorne ja was soll ich sagen hier vorne
ist die komplette Karre auseinander und
ich sehe das Auto jetzt schon ein paar
Tage so aber irgendwie gewöhnt man sich
nicht dran und hat nicht das Gefühl dass
es jetzt in kürzester Zeit wieder
zusammenkmt was es hoffentlich tut so
vordere Wanne wieder raus ich schläf die
jetzt überall hier an damit die dann
vernünftig lackiert werden kann bevor
wir die lackieren kleben wir die aber
natürlich wieder ein aber damit wir die
einfach abschleifen können machen wir
das in ausgebautem Zustand darum kümmere
ich mich jetzt jede kleine Ecke innen
außen überall und dann geht's ab und so
beginnt die Vorbereitung zum Kleben ein
weiteres Mal überall wo lackiert werden
soll anpetten und überall wo geklebt
wird wirklich mit der Maschine
abschleifen ich weiß einigen kommt es
wahrscheinlich so vor als würden wir
immer und immer wieder dieselben
Schritte tun und was soll ich sagen am
Ende ist es so hier geht's ja wirklich
um feine Arbeit jeden Millimeter dass
man am Ende alles vernünftig abdichten
kann dass der Kleber vernünftig hält und
das alles vernünftig so ist wie es sein
soll nämlich so wie es im
reparaturleiffaden von Porsche angegeben
ist wir machen nämlich alles nach
Vorschrift und zwar genauso und
gleichzeitig will ich sagen diese Videos
sind natürlich überhaupt keine Anleitung
irgendwas davon selber zu machen das
muss man mit absoluten Vollprofis machen
und es denen auch komplett komett
überlassen man kann ihn vielleicht ein
bisschen zur Hand gehen so wie ich aber
diese Videos sind definitiv keine
Anleitung und zeigen auch bei weitem
nicht alles was nötig ist um sowas
wirklich nach repleitfaden vernünftig zu
machen also das hier ist eine kleine
Dokumentation was bei uns passiert ist
aber keine Anleitung und nichts
dergleichen bitte nicht verklagen danke
alles perfekt vorbereitet hier unten
überall damit auf die Bühne und auf dem
Boden kein Klebstoff kommt hier alles
perfekt vorbereitet Klebstoffe Nieten
perfekt sortiert alles sauber alles mit
Aceton sauber gemacht und das hier ist
jetzt die le mit der wir den gesamten
Klebstoff auftragen zwei Komponenten und
Spezial Porsche und deswegen herzlich
willkommen meine Damen und Herren zu
einem kleinen Quiz wie viel kosten wohl
die vier Tuben Klebematerial die wir für
den Vorderwagen gebraucht haben a 740 €
B 120 € C
1330 € oder D 1800
€ ihr könnt es euch mit Sicherheit schon
denken die 1800 € ist die richtige
Antwort genau das sind die Kosten mit
denen ich nicht gerechnet habe ich ich
wusste dass es teuer wird aber so teuer
hätte ich selber nicht in einem der
nächsten Videos werden wir alle Kosten
Kauf des Autos Reparaturkosten und so
weiter aufschlüsseln damit ihr wisst wie
viel es kostet den vielleicht dann immer
noch günstigsten 992 GT3 Deutschlands
wieder auf die Straße zu bringen also
vergesst nicht den Kanal zu abonnieren
wenn ihr das nicht verpassen jetzt
müssen wir als erst schauen dass beide
Komponenten gleichzeitig rauskommen dazu
MSS wir
einmal genau das MS wir einmal
[Musik]
verwerfen jetzt kommt das
drauf jetzt müssen wir erstmal den
klebstoffaustritt prüfen dazu machen wir
eine 10 bis 20 cm lange Probe all die
Tests die and hier macht sind am Ende
wichtig um den Wagen potenziell wieder
in die Porsche Garantie zu bekommen es
werden also klebe und nie Protokolle
angefertigt die die genaue Reparatur des
Autos nachvollziehbar machen mehr dazu
aber in einem der nächsten
[Musik]
Video Kleber überall drauf wir haben nur
sehr wenig Zeit deswegen jetzt mit zwei
Leuten die W rein und dann können die
Nieten und Schrauben
[Musik]
rein völlig verrückt nach so vielen
Tagen Vorarbeit dass jetzt die finale
Arbeit wie das neue Teil wirklich vorne
ins Auto setzt so unheimlich schnell
geht ist richtig beeindruckend gibt aber
ein gutes Gefühl man weß wofür man die
ganzen Tage vorher gemacht hat es ist
geklebt es ist genietet jetzt noch das
obere Teil oben drauf und dann ist im
Prinzip der Vorderwagen wieder zurück im
Originalzustand so letzte amshandlung
für heute Heckscheibe raustrennen mein
kamerakind von heute Johann hat mir das
vor zwei Tagen schon erklärt deswegen
kann ich das jetzt hier super einfach
alleine machen viel besser als der
altmodische Draht und deswegen können
das selbst so Leute wie ich jetzt
vernünftig machen
hier Alter die Scheibe ist so kaputt man
hört's nur knacken überall ja aber
machst du sehr sehr gut spitzenmäßig
nichts verlerend von dem was ich vor 48
Stunden erzählt bekommen habe so was ist
das Wichtigste was man beachten mus 90°
spiderkabel auf 90° ne damit er die Last
hier auf die Umlenkrolle tut und nicht
aufs Ganze
Kabel super ja mann da haben wir die
gleich oh
nein speider Kabel kaputt aber wir
konnten die Scheibe raustrennen und
damit den Tag beenden Tag Nummer 7 war
für mich geprägt von kleinen Aufgaben
die aber gemacht werden mssen wie z.B
Folie abziehen und meiner Meinung nach
schreckliche Folie abziehen diese
komischen racingstreifen und Carbonfolie
auf der Haube war wirklich meiner
Meinung nach miserabel also runter damit
weil es muss eh runter und danach den
absoluten Traum von Auspuffanlage
vorzubereiten und mir beim Abrutschen
mies in zwei Fingern zu
schneiden
[Musik]
wie ihr seht auf der Bühne auf der wir
die letzte Woche die letzten anderthalb
Wochen gearbeitet haben steht ein
anderes Auto und das ist gut so denn wir
sind fertig mit all den Arbeiten die wir
an der Karosserie erledigen mussten
bevor wir das Auto lackieren können
bedeutet wiederum das Auto steht in der
Lackiererei und kann dafür vorbereitet
werden neue Farbe zu bekommen genau
darum kümmern wir uns jetzt abschleifen
vorbereiten wieder auseinanderbauen und
dann wird endlich lackiert und so sieht
das Auto jetzt nach all den fertigen
Karosseriearbeiten aus neuer Schweller
neue Tür neue Frontstoßstange und auch
neuer Kotflügel der durch den Aufprall
leicht
verzogen aber zum Lackieren müssen alle
Teile wieder ab und geschliffen werden
geschliffen werden geschliffen werden
noch mal geschliffen werden es wurde
unendlich viel geschliffen während ich
mich genau darum gekümmert habe wurde
der vorder Wagen schon grundiert und
abgedichtet es könnte sein dass es heute
der letzte Tag für mich bei Teegarten
ist wir sind mit drei Mann an meinem
Auto um alles vorzubereiten um heute das
Auto fertig zu lackieren andy ist krank
geworden gute Besserung mein lieber wenn
ich die ganzen Karosseriearbeiten
gemacht habe und hier haben wir jetzt
alles vorbereitet um es abzuschleifen
und dann zu lacken genau damit fange ich
jetzt an hey wer hat es gedacht
schleifen schleifen schleifen all die
Teile die vorher noch nicht von mir in
die Mangel genommen wurden
lackmischbank heißt so viel wie wir
probieren jetzt genau den Farbton meines
Autos zu treffen so sieht das hier aus
überall Farben wir wissen
glücklicherweise über die
Fahrgestellnummer können wir unheimlich
viel herausfinden also natürlich die
ganze Ausstattung und so weiter und den
genauen Farbton und da probieren wir
jetzt so na wie es geht ranzukommen
schaut euch mal hier die ganzen Farben
an die ganzen farbplaketten es wä
natürlich auch schön gewesen direkt das
Auto in irgendeine andere Farbe zu
bringen aber dann hätte Motor hinten
rausgemusst alle anderen Scheiben hätten
rausgemusst die innen Verkleidung auch
wenn die jetzt nur noch so mäßig da drin
liegt aber das wärre noch mal ein paar
Schritte mehr gewesen deswegen habe ich
mich direkt gegen das komplette
neulackieren in irendeer anderen Farbe
entschieden wir werden am Ende Volieren
es muss so passieren auch um den neuen
Lack auf dem neuen Teilen dann direkt
wieder zu schützen und wenn ich
irgendwann keine Lust mehr auf die Farbe
habe ziehe ich die einfach ab und ma
eine neue drauf das geht beim Lacken
natürlich nicht das ist weiß schon eine
ganz gute Basis guckt euch mal alleine
diese ganzen silberfarbtöne an auf den
ersten Blick sehen die alle gleich aus
und dann sieht man aber dass alle in
Nuancen irgendwie unterschiedlich sind
von diesen Kategorien ne von diesen
ganzen Paketen hängen hier
wahrscheinlich jetzt noch mal weiß ich
nicht 200 oder so und in den 200
Kategorien noch mal jeweils 50 Farbtöne
also es ist unglaublich wie viel hier
alleine an Fächern und beispielfarben
hängt schaut euch das mal an das hier
ist so ungefähr die Farbe in der wir den
44 gemacht hatten irgendeine davon sowas
könnte ich mir auch sehr sehr gut auf
dem GT3 vorstellen ein dunkleres aber
hart glänzendes metallic lila finde ich
übelst geil ein dunkel aber glänzendes
so ein British racing green finde ich
übelst krass ganz ganz dunkles Grau
finde ich stark schwarz finde ich zu
langweilig irgendwie so dunkelgrün
dunkellila vielleicht ein dunkles
Metallic Blau könnte ich mir richtig gut
vorstellen ich will ungne eine knallige
Farbe ich will ungne eine helle Farbe
irgendwas hier die ganzen Lilatöne
Blautöne ja und apropos Folie wenn es
irgendjemanden gibt der Lust hat das
Thema mit mir in Angriff zu nehmen
meldet euch gerne per Mail und dann
bringen wir die Karre aussehen wie wir
uns das vorstellen wunderbar
Astronautenanzug aber ihr wisst was das
heißt es geht Richtung
Lackierkabine selber mischen ja so jetzt
mischen wir mal hier den
[Musik]
Lachs perfekt den zehel Gramm
genau so wir müssen auf den Gramm genau
alle Farben reinmachen auf den zehelgm
natürlich weil wir den Farbton halt
genau treffen müssen
[Musik]
5 ja
0 genauso wie es sein
soll was ichflen würde immer nach unten
schütteln okay weil wenn du nicht
schüttelst hängt das alles hier hinten
du drückst auf dann kommt
n und dann hast wie be der ketchupfasche
gen leichtes Problem
[Musik]
dann bisschen zu viel ja das ist noch
vöig wirklich so quas das jetzt noch
oben drauf liegt
[Musik]
wirklich ey
junge
geil ich hät für dich auch aufkommen
soll warte mal kurz bevor du ne das
sieht mal aus hier wie ich Film nicht
drauf ja
so das könen wir jetzt quasi in den
Becher
tun drauf und dann ist das alles
[Musik]
festofahrt ja
ja ich sitze in der Karre schieben den
Wagen in die Lackierkabine und die Jungs
machen
[Musik]
Sound
die Karre steht in der Lackierkabine das
ist abseits von sowas wie detailing nach
dem Lackieren der allerletzte Schritt
bevor der richtige Zusammenbau des Autos
wieder losgehen kann das ist krank und
auch einer der letzten Schritte hier bei
Teegarten so rein
geht
abwaschen dafür brauch ich s noch nicht
okay na
gut also bevor es losgeht drei
reinigungssteps Silikonentferner für die
ganzen Fette und so dann wasserbasierter
und am Ende so ein staubbindetuch damit
sind wir hier hermetisch abgeriegelt und
die Lackierung kann
[Musik]
beginnen
in der Lackierkabine merkt man direkt
wenn man reingeht ist übelst warm und
direkt nebenend dran ist noch ein Ofen
aber die Lackierkabine selbst kannst du
auch Aufheizen ne genau die kann ich
selber jetzt quasi und das hast du
gerade gemacht genau der fäht hoch bis
ger wennen wir eben ein und dann Ken wir
sch geil das war jetzt nur Base CoD das
he nur rein der baslag der schaler kommt
dann
geil also eine Sache muss man wirklich
sagen ich konnte heute morgen nicht so
früh kommen weil ich im Büro normal
arbeiten muss in der Zeit hat Andy das
Auto weitestgehend schon wieder
zusammengesetzt also kodflügel sind dran
Motorhaube ist drin das ist eingestellt
die Dinge wurden alle gelackt sind alle
fertig und jetzt können wir das Auto
weiter zusammensetzen und während ich im
Büro war und irgendwelche Dinge erledigt
hat hat an mir Frühstück mitgebracht
macht ein Kaffee we hier den ganzen Tag
rumrennt und irgendwie dafür sorgt dass
alle happy sind in der Werkstatt und
parallel einfach Kranke Arbeit abreist
also ja auch noch mal in aller
Deutlichkeit öffentlich Andy vielen
vielen Dank für die 10 Tage die ich mit
dir hier bei tgarten war und in der wir
die Karre gemeinsam gemacht haben
richtig krank und jetzt schauen wir uns
das Auto im aktuellen Zustand erstmal an
wie gesagt Kotflügel schon wieder dran
hier vorne schon wieder alles
zusammengesetzt Dichtung ist drin
zweiter kotflüg Motorhaube ist drin und
das sieht einfach traumhaft aus es ist
schon wieder ein halbes Auto das
ducktail das ich auseinander genommen
habe wird meine nächste Aufgabe und das
hier ist der neue Lack noch nicht
poliert es sieht so unheimlich gut aus
hier türeinstieg der Schweller den wir
getauscht haben man sieht nichts aber
auch gar nichts das ist einfach ein
absoluter Traum das halt der Unterschied
tegarten zertifizierter Porsche
Karosseriebauer das das merkt man das
sitzt alles jeder Handgriff jetzt kommt
noch
Kaffee bester Wand Zeit mein absolutes
hassliebeteil am Auto wieder
zusammenzusetzen ich liebe das Teil weil
es die Form des Autos so unheimlich
schick und sportlich macht und ich hasse
das Teil weil es um die oder 8in5000 €
neu kostet und meins war kaputt also
nieen wieder rein diese Luftführung
wieder rein die Blenden und das gehitter
wieder rein und fertig ist mein neues
da
[Musik]
so GT3 macht was aus richtig der flügelt
deswegen ballern wir den jetzt dran ich
habe so lange auf diesen Zeitpunkt
[Musik]
gewartet den ganzen Tag damit verbracht
den Wagen weitestgehend wieder
zusammenzusetzen um ihn vernünftig
transportieren zu können und keine losen
Teile zu
haben am durchziehen um 18 Uhr kommt
jemand der den Wagen abholt und für mich
nach bittburg bringt damit wir über die
gesamte Weihnachts Zeit weiter an dem
Auto arbeiten können heute ist der
allerletzte Tag wo wir hier bei tegarten
irgendwas machen können bevor Wochenende
und Weihnachten losgeht deswegen
klatschen wir die Karre hier zusammen
nur timelapses müssen den Wagen in
bigburg dann eh wieder auseinander
nehmen weil uns Halterungen fehlen weil
Sachen im Porsche Zentrum Trier
angekommen sind die wir jetzt gar nicht
haben also wir werfen das Auto einmal so
zusammen dass wir es vernünftig
transportieren können und machen dann in
Bitburg das alles noch mal vernünftig
jetzt kommt z.B die Rückleuchte das
rückleuchtenband rein aber ist verrückt
weil das Auto jetzt quasi schon fertig
aussieht zumindest immer ein Stückchen
mehr Heckscheibe fehlt noch und was soll
ich sagen das war der erste Moment in
dem man das Gefühl hatte wieder von dem
zumindest teilweise vollendeten Auto zu
stehen und es sah richtig gut
[Musik]
aus
ihr hört wir haben durchgeballert bis
alle hier in den Urlaub sind es ist im
Prinzip niemand mehr in der Firma außer
andy und ich und das weiß ich sehr zu
schätzen hinter mir steht die Karre nahe
zuu ready zumindest sieht es von dieser
Seite hier so aus hier der Scheller ist
dran das Auto sieht fast einsatzbereit
aus wenn man nicht genau dahahin schaut
wenn man nicht genau dahin schaut wenn
man die Airbags nicht beachtet die
fehlenden Sitze die fehlenden Kühler
also ganz fertig ist das Auto noch nicht
aber obwohl das Auto quasi fertig
aussieht gibt es noch unheimlich viel zu
tun die Kühler die Airbags pyofuse eine
richtige scheiße auf Aufgabe die Sitze
den gesamten Innenraum Frontstoßstange
Heckstoßstange also wir haben noch
einiges an Arbeit vor uns aber das
machen wir nicht hier sondern in der
anderen Werkstatt und deswegen machen
wir die Karre jetzt ready und fahren die
genau dorthin 22 Dezember Weihnachten
wird
durchgearbeitet so der Fahrer ist da
geschlossener Transport und die Karre
ist
ready
Alter sieht die Karre aus ich Flip aus
alter ja erst so ein dicken machen und
jetzt nicht rückwärts fahren
[Musik]
ne das Ding mal an alter was für ein
Hänger das so ziemlich das krasse was
gibt komplett geschlossen alles
hydraulisch also ehrenhafter Transport
für dieses Projekt kr
wirklich
krank Alter wie das aussieht ne ich kann
das also also es war mir alles nicht so
bewusst als die Karre noch kaputt war
und jetzt sieht es wieder nach Auto aus
und ich komme nicht darauf klar mir
fehlen die Worte wirklich
[Musik]
unglaublich
fertig überlet du bist
fertig KR Fu hat du die noch rumliegen
ja
hab so Klappe zu auf Tod das war vorerst
meiner Arbeit bei Teegarten wir bringen
die Karre in unsere Werkstatt machen
weiter vielen Dank an Stolte Automobile
die mir hier auf dem Freitagabend kurz
vor Weihnachten die Karre in die andere
Werkstatt bringen wenn ihr irgendwas
braucht Fahrzeugtransport vernünftig
geschlossen für teure Autos für egal was
meldet euch links sind in der
Videobeschreibung vielen vielen dank
alter ich drü dir die Däumchen das alles
klappt ne vielen Dank mach gut vielen
Dank Männer richtig krank macht's gut
Männer viel dank and wirklich vielen
vielen Dank schöne
Feiertage und das war's mit dieser Folge
wenn ihr nicht verpassen wollt wir wir
den GT3 wieder zurück auf die Straße
bringen und was jetzt über die
Weihnachtsfeiertage mit dem Fahrzeug
passiert dann vergesst nicht den Kanal
zu abonnieren wir sehen uns nächste
Woche wieder what the das ist so
krank ach du
scheiße